you went viral on a clip with dorit oh  um the Chic Dory wind chime darling  because she was just all a flutter with  you you got into the chicness she  thought everything was so Chic so Chic  so I was wondering if you would play a  game with me Chic or not in honor of  Dory kemsley a gingerbread  um house wow Drew you're just throwing  it that is completely Halloween  decorated is this Chic or not Chic did a  child make it  um say yes  [Laughter]  now is it cheek or not did a child make  it yes and it's the chicest  Halloween gingerbread house I have ever  seen in my life  vampire's blood candle and it has the  sweet smell like strawberry night  blooming Jasmine and Transylvanian Plum  so not cheap thank you so much for  having me